Now that we have verified that our project is working,
we can move on to creating the additional menus
that we need for a full loop to happen.
In order to do this,
the first thing that we are going to do
is create another widget blueprint,
and we're gonna call this new one game over UMG.
So let's go ahead and create that
and open it up inside of the editor.
So again, to create any widget blueprint,
we're gonna right click,
user interface, widget blueprint.
We will select user widget as the parent,
and then we will call this shift WB or widget blueprint
and game over.
Apologies, my shift key is broken,
so my sometimes mine did not come out all that great.
Let's do that again, underscore.
All right.
Let's go ahead and double click on this to open it up.
And I'm gonna make this white screen.
Now, as we've done with things in the past,
we are going to add an image
to this particular background button.
We're gonna add a lot of things to this,
but basically we're gonna add an image.
We're gonna set it to full screen and select a color.
So this is gonna give us just a pure color background
for simplicity sake.
We're gonna put some text on it as well as a button.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor
and do this first part.
Right, so first things first,
let's go ahead and put a canvas panel on here.
We have something to work with.
And then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna look for an image.
We're gonna drag this image
right on top of our canvas panel.
And right now it's just gonna sit up right there
and that's okay.
And next we are going to grab some text
and we'll put the text on there
and then we're gonna grab a button
and we're gonna put the button on there.
So again, all of this is kind of just stuck up here
and we're going to fix some stuff
so that all of this will look like an actual screen.
Now, the first thing we're gonna do is with our image,
we're gonna go to our anchor full screen,
make sure we don't have any offsets
and set the color to whatever color we want.
The reason we wanna do this is we want our image
to always maintain this aspect ratio.
So to do this again, we're gonna come here,
we're gonna grab our image and from our anchors,
we have this full screen.
I'm just gonna hit control while I do that
and that's boom, gonna pop that to full screen right there.
Now let's give it a color.
So we're gonna click on color.
I'm gonna make mine light greenish,
maybe more on the orangey side,
we thought it's kind of cool,
maybe a little more saturated.
There we go.
Whatever color you want is totally fine.
So what we're gonna do now is something like this.
We are going to have the game over final score
and then a restart button.
So as we have done in the past,
I want you to rearrange the stuff
on your particular image,
or I should say your particular UMG
to match what we have on the screen.
And I'm gonna do that now.
Right, once you have something like this,
the next thing that we're gonna do
is as we did with our text for our UI,
we are going to go to our final score
and then what we're gonna do is
we are going to create a binding for our final score,
I should say,
and we are going to get the current score
and then print that out so that when the game is over,
you see the end score.
So again, to do this, what we're gonna do,
we're gonna come back over here to Unreal,
we're gonna grab our final score,
and then under content text,
we're going to bind, create binding.
Once the binding is kind of up,
we're going to get player,
we want the player pawn, okay?
And then from the player pawn,
we are going to cast to the vehicle advanced pawn.
We're then going to click on this
and convert it to a pure cast.
And if you have forgotten that you do that,
that could be one reason why things aren't working.
But remember, again, right clicking on the cast,
we'll turn this to a pure cast,
allowing us to bypass some of those checks there.
What we're gonna do after that is we're gonna pull off
this as vehicle advanced pawn,
and we're going to get, and we might have to,
oops, and it helped, maybe I'd spell that right.
And get current score, there we go.
And we are going to need to format this text.
And remember, as we did before,
we can put in what we want here.
So we can put in score and then plug like that,
and then finally plug this in to here.
So let's go ahead and compile and save.
Now, next part, what we're gonna do
is we are going to click on the,
so that when we restart,
we can actually do something different.
Basically, we're going to restart our map,
but there is one thing that we have to check on first.
We need to make sure we know the exact level name
of the level that we wanna restart.
So in our project right now,
I was to just move this over,
which is the vehicle example map.
So again, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna grab our button here.
We're gonna scroll down to our on clicked
and hit the plus sign right here.
And when this button is clicked, what do we wanna do?
Well, we want to set input mode to game only.
And then we want to get our player,
oops, get player.
We wanna get our player controller, right?
Because we wanna set the input mode game only
on our player controller.
And then what we wanna do
is we wanna open our level by name.
So open level by name.
And what is the name of that?
Well, the name of that is vehicle example map.
So let's just make sure that I spell this right.
Now, if you were dealing with another map
or inside of another project or something like that,
you would need to make sure that this open level by name
is the level that you wish to open.
But this is the node that you use to open any level.
So you can even have this on a trigger.
So when your player jumps into the trigger,
you could use the open level by name
to progress your level action.
So that's very, very, very cool stuff.